foreign
okay I'm going to call the interim study
committee on house bill 1229 to order
thank you very much to all of you who
are here chairman Ladd representative
Lucas representative Hall representative
so um
representative Woodcock and
representative Ellison you asked for uh
an explanation from the doe of the
school meals data figures that were
given to us at the last meeting do you
feel that you satisfactorily
congratulations you you have arrived
Kelly
okay so
um what I asked that people do is to
prepare themselves for the meeting uh by
reading the research packet of
information that Jennifer Ford provided
us on the 5th of August so that we can
take a look at where this research came
from and what the impetus was behind it
so at some point in time in July
Jennifer Ford put out an email that said
probably much to her Chagrin at this
point if anyone needs any research done
this would be a good time to ask for it
because it's kind of quiet in the LLP
right now
so through some subsequent email
I requested that Jen look at which
states have similar demographics to New
Hampshire
and if she wouldn't mind doing a bit of
a compare and contrast between what
we're doing with food services and what
those other states were doing so in
particular
she looked at Delaware Maine New Mexico
Vermont and West Virginia
and that's the summary of information
that you have in the memo in front of
you
so
barring anybody feeling like they can
quote Page by Page uh I guess what we'll
do is just take a look at Delaware and
see whether or not there's anything of
interest in that information
I for one
um
was immediately taken
that an RSA had been evidently drafted
in Delaware that says that all public
schools including Charter Schools must
offer breakfast through an alternative
service model so as we all know the use
of that word must is exceptionally
meaningful because it's not an option if
if it's a must on page two the research
goes on and looks at the state funding
for Food Service employees in Delaware
which again was something that was an
interesting concept
um
the state supplements up to 70 percent
of the salaries of food service staff
with funds not derived from the school
lunch options in particular the statute
reads the salaries prescribed in this
section are for school lunch manager and
district managers and shall be paid from
State funds
then it goes on to talk about uh where
the
you know cafeteria staff where the cooks
and and service people are funded from
and that states a minimum of 25 percent
of the salary prescribed in subsection C
shall be paid by the state from funds
not derived from school lunch operations
so I I'm only assuming and jump in here
if anybody has a different
interpretation of it
um I'm assuming that that funding would
have been roadblocked for individual
districts without
it being subsidized to a certain extent
from the state coffers is that how you
foreign
kins
well I'll tell you I feel a whole lot
better about you as a whole because I
first thought to myself well clearly
these people have not read this page uh
and then I thought
well can these people read this page
because there's nothing there's no
feedback from either side so uh yeah so
that state funding portion uh has to do
with subsidizing local districts I
believe and that's I don't think that's
a foreign concept to us because we've
heard about the roadblock that having to
hire additional staff and food directors
it was 70 for the food director and
managers and 25
of the cost of cooks and cafeteria
workers
the other thing that Delaware did
um
not that I'm an idiot savant on the
package but I did have page two in front
of me until Jen took it
they required that uh charter schools
which evidently are also public in
Delaware uh provide some sort of
breakfast and lunch program at least to
kids who qualify for free or reduced
lunch
so
I don't know how I feel about that
because I I
Charter Schools tend to be small
and I don't know how you would protect
the confidentiality of the students
if Kelly's nodding her head back there
if
you have
12 kids in a classroom and four of them
have to go get their lunch from a
cafeteria or whatever an eight of them
or brown bag in it from home yeah
representative fleecus
well that actually starts on the bottom
of page one and I notice it says all
public schools including Charter Schools
participating in the community eligible
eligibility provision to offer that so
the question is do they have the option
of not participating
yeah that's a good question
it's a good question
throughout this packet what you're going
to find is that
some states require that all public
schools and or Charter Schools
participate in the national school lunch
program but then as soon as they require
it they also allow for the opportunity
to apply for waivers so I would think
that each of those individual states
must have some sort of threshold
Financial threshold by which they're
judging what
actually presents as an undue burden on
a local District because on the one hand
they're saying You must participate and
then on the other hand but using myself
as an example
Bedford New Hampshire is not going to
apply for a waiver and have it granted
if they choose not to participate in the
National lunch program
however
someone else's Community might very well
you know whether it's uh property values
or the burden of the school budget on
the community or whatever they may in
fact qualify
thank you thank you Jen
lucky thing you came to see us today
John
Wallace is the question that will sort
of fall up in your commentary
um we we now have those uh I think it's
40 schools or 30 schools
um 30 45th exact number somewhere
between those two uh that do participate
in our lunch program but yet out of
participating in The Breakfast program
correct so there has to be some uh thank
you again it has to be some way that
they do that
you know they have that option well I
don't think it's mandatory though but
the uh and certainly if um the doe wants
to chime in on this feel free to jump up
at the microphone
um but it's not in in these statutes it
says it's mandatory to participate in
the school lunch program and in many of
the states it's mandatory if you offer a
lunch program then you must offer
breakfast but that's not in our current
statute so uh it's optional and that was
that was something that was moving down
so in Maine all public schools must
participate in the national school lunch
program but there's an exemption for
secondary schools and grades 9 through
12. in a subsection of the statute so
again you know there I I believe that
the spirit of that is in reading the
statute is to allow for communities that
prove that they can sustain a program to
be required to do so but in communities
where in in some of the states it's you
know if more than 80 percent of the kids
in the school district qualify for free
and reduced lunch then they can in fact
be waived off but I think it goes like
Maine
um if you I did not photocopy all of the
literature that Jen provided from the
main statutes you have them
electronically in email that I sent out
to you on or around August 5th or 6th
somewhere in there
um
it's there for you to go back and and
look through because I think the
language is fairly interesting and
certainly will be moving forward for us
but uh Maine has instituted a universal
no-cost School meals program
so
there's uh in the literature that is not
here but you do have electronically are
the fiscal statement on it I think it
was 34 million was the 34 million in
change right Nancy's nodding her head uh
was the was the total on on no cost
they also uh established something
called the meals for students fund which
is a non-lapsing dedicated fund within
the Department of Education
to provide funds for the cost to the
state to pay the difference between the
federal reimbursement
for a free breakfast or lunch and the
full price of breakfast or lunch for
students that are ineligible for free or
reduced let me say that again because
there are so many eligibles and
ineligibles when you're looking at the
universal meals program there are kids
that would qualify for
free lunch so schools would be
reimbursed full amounts for them the
federal full amount there are kids that
are eligible for reduced cost meals and
therefore the government the federal
government would reimburse at that rate
Then There are kids that are ineligible
for free and reduced meals that's
basically everybody else so this fund
this meals for student fund was
established to come up with the funding
mechanism
for the state to use to fund meals for
kids that are not being reimbursed from
at least that's my read on it if you'll
remember correctly I asked Jennifer at
the last meeting if she was prepared to
answer any questions on This research
um
she would have to be she would have to
be a full-time expert in school meals
programs Nationwide to be able to answer
these questions so I think it was
somewhat of an unrealistic ask but
Jen jump in if I present to anything
that you take issue with will you jump
okay
well you may be digging
um for different reasons it may not be
for this study committee you may be
digging for the people that come after
us
the other thing that Maine is looking at
uh is
providing summer Food Services which
was part of the covet relief effort you
know kids were getting food right
through the summer now that New
Hampshire is no longer particip well the
program Ended as of September 30th and
we uh did not
fill out applications to continue
through any of the available means so
moving through the future that means
that summer meals you know would not be
offered that they would end with the
school year unless uh
uh unless other Provisions had been had
been made in some schools some schools
qualify for summer meal programs because
of the population
but again it's that
you know if you're hungry and your
parents make
thirty eight thousand dollars a year for
a family for it does that mean that you
you know you're ineligible to be fed
yeah under under current law does so uh
we'll have to take a look at that at
some point in time jump in here you guys
if you have any questions or comments to
uh
they also main look at look at the state
domain name is it's their model the way
life ought to be is that
uh
their former moral correct that that was
that well they also had those signs that
on the highway that said stay alert
which I thought were pretty important as
well the people from New Hampshire yes
exactly wake up uh they established a
local produce fund
under 20 a main revive statute the local
food fund which I think you know we we
heard from our own uh Farm to school
people last time we met
and I believe that a lot of what they
were proposing through the bill that did
not go through last time around but
we're likely to see again is uh in Maine
it's a five thousand dollar per School
allocation
if you purchase foods from local theirs
is very specific in the sense that uh
it's from a farmer a farmer's
Cooperative a local food Hub a local
food processor or Food Service
distributor
and it's only to be used to purchase
Foods grown or produced in Maine
it's authorized to accept public and
private Revenue so again they're looking
for alternative funding sources
and it's not lapsing so I can't imagine
that it would lapse anyhow if you're
talking about five thousand dollars but
but that it looks to they look to be uh
somebody who Maine looks to be somebody
who's put looks to be a state that's
dungeons or comments on Delaware and
Maine
representative Ellison or more general
question Madam chair could you refresh
our memory as in in terms of the charge
of this subcommittee and what what is
expected or what alternatives might be
expected at the end of this well it's an
interesting question because you know I
laughed early on about the study
committee to determine if we needed a
study committee
it's not seeming so funny anymore now it
seems like the study committee may be
recommending that we need a continued
study committee our charge is uh to
basically say yes or no
to recommending future legislation
we do not have to write the legislation
we can make recommendations in fact
chairman Ladd who I sought some advice
from at one point in time said that um
yes that if in fact you're moving
forward with a with a recommendation for
yes then it would be helpful to uh
gather the committee's thoughts and talk
about
potential legislative areas that we
might want to devote some time to
does that answer your question it's very
helpful thank you
chairman Ladd
in looking at several of these which you
haven't come to yet but uh including
Delaware
there's a requirement that the state
supplement up to 70 or the others in
Delaware
where are the dollars and are these
people that are working in this program
eligible for State retirement are they
eligible for the benefits within the
school district that there may be
working maybe I.E Medical Dental
um those would be added costs which
would be captured
in in some states by the local other
states partially by the local and
partially by the state but is something
we should get a handle on as far as the
retirement how's that you know because
that's always something that's coming to
haunt us dealing with the teacher system
right now the police fire
community college system definitely has
got an issue with that so um
yeah that's an area which you should you
know if you're going to move something
forward put that as a concern that the
state's going to be working where's
where's the retirement and how they
I I don't have an answer to your
question but I recognize the importance
representative Woodcock thank you uh
default from representative comment um
wouldn't their assumption wreck be that
whatever these I'm just asking whatever
the school district currently is doing
for their their culinary staff would
continue in terms of if they pay every
time if they pay in why would that
change
well you're adding to the program it's
not something will you turn your
microphone on your answer to the program
by way of a state statute
and the local benefits the packages for
medical and dental and all usually and
always come from the local so you're
talking about the local having to
contribute some dollars to this as well
um who's going to make the decision
um yeah it may the local may say well
we'll just tie it in but that's there's
going to be an additional cost depending
upon the type of system you've set up
certainly the person that's employed is
going to have to contribute some to it
I guess I'm a little confused my
thinking is if I'm working 30 hours a
week in school X right now and as a
member of the The Culinary staff in the
kitchen and say the chef whatever
um and they're they're providing x
amount of meals and for 30 hours a week
and next year the year after year
afterward they change the uh funding
mechanism but that's not going to change
my 30 a week if my hours don't expend
this there's a contract for the culinary
folks and the the cafeteria folks what
they already have so if nothing's going
to change except how it's funded I don't
understand why that would change the
local contribution if they don't offer
Dental now they don't offer medical now
which they may but if they don't I mean
that would be a whole new contract
correct
I think we ought to look at okay uh we
we're seeing that when we're looking at
teacher shortages right now retirements
come up to be an issue okay uh that we
need to look at uh there's a lot of
different ways of doing this could be
through contract and services okay
um and that could be buried into the the
labor costs yeah I think all right so
it's a point I think you're both right
right I think that if additional staff
is needed because we're expanding
breakfasts and the number of kids that
are being fed at lunch or whatever then
we have to be mindful of whether or not
there are benefit and retirement
implications
uh if additional staff is not needed
then it shouldn't affect it right and
correct and it's nice to hear that
representative both corrected
you're you're both yeah you're both
correct oh we agree on many things out
of here
um but that that being said that the
staff um representative Mullen that
you're talking about
there is a contract in place uh already
in these school systems so whatever I
guess my point is whatever they're
offering now is local costs they've only
seem to be extended if in fact we extend
the hours to add new staff for local
thoughts correct it doesn't mean that
they necessarily have to get a a benefit
uh like I say dental insurance they
aren't getting it now right okay that's
my point yes okay thank you thank you
representatively constitu have a comment
well I was
I'm just gonna say that yes if they're
not hiring new staff but if they're
putting but if they are hiring new staff
that's a cost we have mandated to the
local people and are we you know Mandy
are we mandating they spend money
without providing the money for it and
so that's the question if all of the
people if their contract says they get
medical and dental and now they have to
hire two more staff because we've told
them they had to provide breakfast
who's paying
for that additional cost that they're
going to have that's the question we
okay rapidly moving on to New Mexico
breakfast after the Bell required in
certain schools
namely schools that have 85 percent or
more of their student body that is
funding for breakfast after the Bell
again this is one
um
where the state is establishing they
evidently have a pot of money
and what they've said is that the
disbursements of the funding is going to
be based on the percentage of kids in
the building that qualify for free and
reduced lunch so your neediest buildings
are going to get money first
with the idea that it's uh that
disbursement is done on a needs basis
which is again an interesting
concept and I have more questions than
the answer is when I when I read that
uh no question for you in that one Sue
yes sir um if you're looking at for
example how we are reimbursing schools
for tuition the Career Technical
education centers
um if there are more kids that are
qualifying than the previous year of
course you're gonna have to pay more for
tuition but we allocate blank nine
million dollars a year so the way we're
allocating those tuition dollars after
we pay transportation is by a prorated
or a proportionate amount if we divide
the number of students in you may the
state may say we're supposed to allocate
75 percent of tuition but in fact it's
only 62 percent so there is a difference
there
um but if I were one of those districts
that had this program and I'm the you
know the on the bottom side of there
where our percentage of free and reduced
in the building is a smaller number but
I'm still having to serve students and
have the staff there the same staff
there to cook and all that
I'd be kind of you know concerned that
I'm not getting any of that
reimbursement because you ran out of the
money in the pot so if you if we go
forward the program right here I'd like
to make sure that all programs are
supporting you uh the the school to that
has those type of students in it uh it's
just going to be probably a good
rationale for the district to be upset
if they don't receive that money and to
thank you
uh the next point out of the New Mexico
research that I would draw your
attention to is a point that seems to be
uh fairly popular in a number of states
and that is
providing no-cost meals breakfast and
lunch for kids who are eligible for
reduced
meals
so rather in other words eliminating
basically the reduced meal category and
just making it a
free meal for anybody who qualifies for
either free or reduced uh
and the again the the funding for that
the the department shall provide funding
to each School District that administers
such a program
and when calculating the amount due if a
school district or Charter School is not
previously had a program
the department will work with the school
to determine an accurate estimate of
funding for the program
that means you're going to be hiring six
concept that I of
um
the stigma of free and reduced meals is
something that we talked about at length
during the last session and you know if
there is a way that students can
who qualify can receive meals without
having to have attention drawn to
themselves because they're in one
category or the other depending upon
what the price tag is then I think we
certainly
could consider that
all right moving on to Vermont
all public schools must participate in
the National lunch program and the
no cost breakfast and lunches for
students eligible for reduced price
meals there it is again so now that was
that was just what I was referring to in
New Mexico and now Vermont is doing the
same thing
uh 20 22 2023 free breakfast and lunches
for all public school students so
they extended
this law will be repealed effective July
1 2023
but calls on the State Education Agency
to report to the legislature no later
than January 15 on the impact and status
of implementation of the law with
various participation data and
strategies for minimizing the use of
State funds that's what I I'm very
interested in that it also calls on the
joint fiscal office to report on
possible Revenue sources including and
here comes the death of it the expansion
of
sales tax the enactment of an excise tax
on sugar sweetened Beverages and other
sources of revenue not ordinarily used
for general fund purposes so at least in
the state of Vermont
it looks like they are
um
looking at either instituting a new tax
doing something to the sales tax base
yes sir
and I know this has been recorded So I I
ask you to read uh
um repeat or present the last paragraph
of this from one piece I find that
critical
the one that starts despite the
perspective repeal okay thank you
despite the perspective repeal the law
includes a section declaring the
legislature's intent to use information
collected to identify the revenue
amounts and sources necessary to
establish long-term funding for
Universal School meals
so they're the review is not a diminish
of the program it's just saying let's
find it by the way right okay and I do
have a follow-up to that yes sir you
know or if there's an attorney if you
want to know if if Vermont is a annual
budget or biennial budget Brickman
always lives over there okay is it may I
ask sure is the Vermont budget annual
okay so they're looking at where they
were appealing it and bring it back in
the same calendar year I'm thinking it
was the annual budget we're in New
Hampshire we couldn't do that because it
wouldn't be because it's by anyway yeah
I mean obviously the I think the intent
I think the intent of the statement
the last thing is to yeah is to indicate
that even if the law is repealed
that they would be they'll be using the
feeding information to
find another Revenue Source if they have
to to yeah to keep it going thank you
thank you very much here
what's the student population in Vermont
do you have any ideas
[Music]
um
I'm looking at the cost of this program
being 29 million dollars
but I've always been on the impression
that it's almost half what we have
well I can tell you based on 20 whoops
2018 and 2019 our numbers
it's estimated uh that if we based on
the 1819 numbers which are the last ones
that were pre-covered it would cost us
uh 24 million 696 thousand nine hundred
and twelve dollars and 80 cents uh to
feed everybody
after Federal after the federal
reimbursement those are the eligible yep
prayer reduced no this is everybody
that's 164 000 kids everybody yep
and
Vermont has two our kids than we do
and yet ours is coming out at less costs
that mean we have
a lower poverty rate committed or we we
might have a lower participation rate in
the school meals program you know it's
based on the number of meals served
feeding everybody over there
yeah if they're feeding everybody
then we may have a higher participation
rate we may have a lower number because
we're getting more money back from the
federal government
but if we got less money back it would
cost us even more
because we just can't guess that we
don't know yeah right right I mean we
have to base numbers on something and
what we're basing it on are the total
meals
that were Freedom reduced the
reimbursement rate on breakfast and
lunch frame reduced and then the regular
the number of regular meals served six
but this comes from uh
the doe so if you have questions then
I would say take advantage uh
I know okay Kelly Rambo from the
Department of Education
um so the document that
um representative Mullen is speaking
about
um she's in fact correct in um
describing it so the way that it is
written out is the
difference between the
um what the federal reimbursement what
they would pay and then the state would
pick up the difference as far as that's
concerned so
um also
um representative Woodcock is also
correct
um in stating that it is very hard to
figure out the exact number that this
would be due to the fact that we are
basing the numbers um in front of you
off of meals that are served so if you
were to want a different number on every
single student that was in the state of
New Hampshire
that could possibly get a meal that
would be a different number than the
number that's in front of you so the
number that's in front of you is actual
meals that were served in all of the
Child Nutrition national school lunch
program meals for 1819 but if you're
wanting a different number that's
something that I can get you um as well
it might be a shocking amount
to see that the difference between those
two but if it's something that you're
representative Ellison uh following
along with that then and trying to get
to the shocking number uh we would if if
the participation rate it free reduced
prices fit 40 percent or whatever it is
52 percent
you're you're saying if we push it to a
hundred percent there would be a new
figure is that what you're saying
um yes and no
um so the the number that's in front of
you is based off of the meals that were
served for free the meals that were
served for reducing the meals that were
served for paid
um something to consider and think about
in the states that we're speaking about
and how they're running their programs
they still need to collect in order to
get Federal reimbursement they still
need to collect the application so they
still need to determine those students
free reduced or paid
um so depending on the outcome of that
that's going to be what's going to
change your federal reimbursement and
that would in fact then change the state
let's call it State match or state state
funding
follow-up I'm sure yes then then I guess
I I don't want to do a lot a lot more
calculations but if a hundred percent of
this student families students in the
state who are who are eligible for free
reduced price launch or fed regardless
of whether they put an application or
not what would that I'm interested in
that figure
and I can I can get that for you that
would be great thank you
representative flickas
just trying to figure out the number
that you have so you looked at
my right the not just the free and
reduced lunch but all kids who bought
lunch from the school as in that would
be the meal served that's correct and
the rest would have brought their lunch
or whatever that's correct and so
if we were to say well let's feed
everybody
that number may change because kids who
bring their lunch if it's free might
take the free lunch
and so we would have to make a new
estimation that's correct
um and so the way that the program has
run in the past for the past two years
due to covid was
there was no eligibility determination
needed for that so that's why everybody
received a free lunch then in turn for
those meals every school received the
free Federal reimbursement rate but now
that we are shifting back into the mslp
national school lunch program
reimbursement that's when you're going
to see the free reduced and and the paid
reimbursements from the federal
government so would we be able to get an
estimate based on the last two years
of what the basic cost per student
getting lunch is and then apply that to
the earlier ones when we had more kids
in school
so
um I just want to make sure I understand
so I get you the correct information so
you want the what the free reimbursement
was for last year
the free reimbursement rate from the
federal government and apply that to
um the 1819
yeah basically what did it cost us when
we were feeding everybody for free
what was the actual cost I mean yes I
know we got money back from the
government but what did it actually cost
us to provide that per pupil and then
multiply that by the
numbers from the sem 1819 because those
are more like the number of pupils we
have
okay it makes sense I can get you that
number so
um
it would be for for me to get you that
number for
um
two years ago maybe
two oh no they weren't in the building
oh so it's going to be completely
different never mind I'm just trying to
figure out but we know meals served so
we can figure out per pupil cost and
multiply that if everybody decided to
eat a free meal as opposed to bringing
their lunch
so we have um how many meals were served
for last year
um and the way that it's in our system
um they're all it's free
breakfast and free lunch we don't have
it separate out in free reducing paid
because of the way that the claims were
paid out for last year for the federal
reimbursement
um so I can take the total amount of
breakfast that was served last year
um I believe I might have worked
um
Jen with you on that
um so I will I'll reconfigure that and
and get those numbers for you
um and if it's not what you're looking
for then I'll try and try my best to get
you what you are looking just just
trying to get an idea of what if
everybody ate lunch what would it really
cost yes yeah and I can tell you that in
in federal reimbursement
um we have pushed out over a hundred
million dollars out of our office for
last year alone thank you
okay yeah I'd be interested in
I mean I know that we have
well I we have not tallied but the
455 000 free breakfast the 65 000 what
What's the total number of meals served
in 1819 and then the total number of
meals served last year
just as a comparison in numbers because
I
um
did cafeteria Duty for 39 years of my
life
and I believe that even if the food was
free there would be some kids that would
brown bag it because they just
yeah in fact members of this committee
have taken great joy in teasing me for
being a brown bagger for the past four
years and not
availing myself of the opportunity of uh
cafeteria dining
so so I think that there would be you
know that there would be kids that I
don't I don't think it's a foregone
conclusion that just because it's free
they're going to eat it
and so what I can do is I can provide
the total meals for
um
in its entirety for 1819 between
breakfast and lunch I won't break it
down for your reduced paid
um and then um I will do the same for 21
22 and then we can I'll give you what
the federal reimbursement rate was for
free and then we can figure out the
equation from there to get the the total
amount great
yes sir representative Woodcock yes
thank you I don't know why
representative Hall would do that do you
keep on ridiculing you a bunch of brown
bag but
um just a question for uh Kenneth I may
uh is the
percentage rate of youngsters to
participate across the board uh annually
in our free reduced meals relatively
similar every year or is there a big I
mean is one year like 25 is in this 12
or is it normally a certain number
within a margin so every year so you
um I
I'm trying to remember all the numbers
that I had pulled um for the committee
for last time
um I would say it's within you know 10
um up or down um give or take
um and all of that information is
um is on the the web
um our web page
um but as far in my capacity and my role
just for this
um I would say it's either
um up or down
um but I'm I just uh can I ask you
clarifying real sure
um just uh she likes you
most definitely without hesitation thank
you
um so I just want to make sure I
understand your question correctly are
you asking in in the entirety of the
like let's say the United States or just
for for our our state in and of itself
um yes I would say um give or take up um
up or down 10
um in that in that range yes for the
data that we have okay
yes sir is
um does the federal uh rate change uh
during the year once it said it stays
that way I was thinking about the cost
of food products across uh the country
and internationally right now and the
inflation now is international so is
that the rate going to change will be
adjusted once it's set annually they
just set it and keep it regardless
um it's set annually so
um the reimbursement rates
um normally I say
um would come out in July or
um maybe August they were pretty late
this year for um and they came out in
August but they normally the the rates
run from July to um to June 30th so for
this particular year the rate was a
little bit higher than it normally was
due to the the act that that was in
place for that so that will stay the
same until the end of this school year
and then once a new school year begins
new rates will come out okay
um if I may I like to present just an
anecdotal fact
um in preparing for today's meeting I
was speaking with the family liaison in
one of the schools in our district uh
back home and asked about what she saw
for the difference if any with people in
the brown bags and the those that don't
yada yada and what she said was the most
significant difference she saw that was
youngsters who typically uh did not were
not in that breakfast lunch category
we're stopping to taking breakfasts to
go she said they they come in all the
time we wouldn't have had breakfast but
they didn't care she said this is the
biggest thing she saw when the federal
government came to free to do this was
the youngsters in the elementary school
and there for elementary schools those
kids would come down and eagerly take
their lunch to go back in that period
um that would just before never met any
criteria and never had it she said
that's the biggest difference she had so
um is my last my last I hope last
question yeah um if you were and I know
we spoke about this earlier and
representative Ellison followed me up
and understanding it again if there was
a number if we took the number that
representative Ladd said 164 000 I think
was the number of Youth of youngsters in
New Hampshire his school is that Brooke
is that right 164. that's around it okay
so we took that number of 164 youngsters
in New Hampshire uh and we have to K-12
schools right now uh and assume that all
qualify and the federal system of uh
Alicia talked about signing up or the
Medicaid production that all the options
looking in fact we sign up
is there a can you give us a guesstimate
uh what two figures what the cost might
be for the program
uh for all 164 and what particularly uh
what the guesstimation may be in your
best you know now
um for what it might cost for the State
of New Hampshire assuming all the
federal reimbursement fees that come to
your office would came in like they
should
um what would it what would it cost what
were we looking at for a number of
defeat to do a two of them on to do or
you know to feed all the youngsters
every youngster that comes through that
they make sure they have healthy meals
to start the day and and be fed at least
two days two meals a day what would that
cost to stay in New Hampshire
you may not have a secret of your tongue
I mean I am not a mathematician that is
for sure
um so that's a critical figure
um
if you go off by five cents we'll be
aggravated
um so I will have to get that cost for
you
um but I just wanted to
it's very difficult to get that number
without having the free and reduced
information because that's the point of
how we're going to get that figure that
the state is going to need to pay for
um and to make up that difference so we
need to have what the federal government
is going to be providing so that
um I mean I could definitely give you a
number if
um you told me that there was a 164
000 that were reduced we can you know we
can get you that number if they're the
federal reimbursement was going to be
the reduced rate I could do the
difference between and I could get you
that number
um if they were all free then the
federal government would pay for them
all and would cost you nothing
um so we need to have some sort of data
to be able to kind of plug in and play
so to speak to get a figure for um for
what you're asking
yes sir thank you I only asked that I'm
not trying to be pursue this any further
than the committee may want to know what
they're going to vote but if in fact
anything comes out in legislative
requests next year there's going to be
that FN number next to it so somewhere
between January and the start of session
if there's any legislative that comes
here that that number is going to have
to be calculated somehow
because there will be a cost that
someone's gonna have to look at with an
ethnic number of legislation so I'm just
saying that no and um and I understand
what you're saying I just it's hard to
get the number without having
um
the free and reduced information to
offset the federal government cost yeah
one more Yep is October is October 31
the the deadline for for participation
that or September when the kids come to
school
fix this year right now today
um for the the Department of Education
it we collect that data in October
um they can apply for free and reduce at
any point in time during the school year
um so there's no deadline for them to to
apply for it but we we do data point
collection yes October 31 is the end of
the data point collection yes so so for
the projection we're talking about
somewhere after say November
december-ish somewhere at some point doe
prior to January would have at least the
number
um that are there this year I think he's
as a baseline absolutely two thousand
something better than something this
matter is good and I appreciate you
getting that and no disrespect but it's
six five years old
it's not your fault you bring Kobe but
that so when we go back in you know what
I mean yeah no I mean I'm just saying
that that's all I do think it's thank
you very helpful though to be able to
look
um at
ratios and percentages uh from 2018 and
19. you know what not what percentage of
kids were reduced were free we're full
Fair
um because we would hope that that's at
least a ballpark figure and that's why I
was asking percentage rate over here
yeah thank you
question
um I wanted to answer yep answer
um so what I can do is I can use the
um
eligibility from 2021 so you can have an
answer before so you can have some sort
of answer based off of the free reduced
and then everybody else from the 164
that does not fit into the free or
reduce would be uh would be paid so then
you'd have that cost associated with
that does that sound that is superb okay
thank you
representative Lucas I just wanted to
comment on what you said about the
number of kids grabbing lunches and
picturing back when I was in school and
I had I mean breakfasts I had breakfast
every morning but believe me if I'd have
been able to grab and go it would have
meant I could have slept in later I'd
have grabbed and gone
you had to walk up and down the hill
chairman Ladd thank you very much for
the Department
um is there any way that we can find out
in the high school
all the students which are eligible I
know that I used to as a school
principal by looking at the elementary
applications that came in we'd also see
that they had X number of students in
the high school and we gave credit for
those kids even those students very
rarely in the high school brought the
application back in
so if we were to add in all those
youngsters that are from eligible
families I think we'd get a better
number another thought that I've had
after listening to conversation here
that where I see this happening in
Vermont right now and I see it happening
even at the high school where I have a
couple high schoolers attending at St
Johnsbury Academy which is a Vermont
high school and then some in the Middle
School in West Barnet uh the ones in
West Barnett absolutely depend upon that
breakfast even though they're capable of
having but they usually are getting up
late trying to get on the bus and
there's probably no breakfast in them
but they get to school and there is
would it be but the ones that get to the
academy which has a thousand kids and
it's about one-third size Pinkerton but
it's a good side school
they go right into their structured
schedule day where they have to go and
all the block scheduling and they're on
their way and they very rarely have the
chance to do something like this because
they're traveling from eight different
communities and they time it so they
just get that they're on time for
getting into what they call they call it
Chapel but it's basically the First
Assembly of the day where they give all
the information about what's happening
that day and then on to their classes
and they're required to be in that first
session so I it would be a good idea to
try to phase in a program like this
phase it in first with the grades which
I feel are really critical and that's
your they're all critical yes but the
Elementary grades K through six or or
even if it's a k through eight building
to face this program in see how it's
work and then take the next leap to the
high school are there any states which
are phasing this type of program and
rather than going Whole Hog like Vermont
by fy23 we're gonna We appropriate these
dollars and everybody's in the program
yeah I I don't know about states that
are facing them in the only information
that I asked for from uh Jennifer four
was on States that had similar
demographics to New Hampshire so there
may be other states out there that are
doing a whole host of things that we
haven't even taken a look at we were
looking at you know population
uh annual income size that kind of
so uh yeah that would take additional
research yeah in the Medicaid
Eligibility thing which we've talked so
much about in the past is absolutely
critical to this yeah they met more
students it will more students we we've
got that data from the Health and Human
Service that's the direct certification
yes yeah USDA they're they're involved
with this and there are some states
doing rather than free and reduce f r
program now they're using the Medicaid
information to identify all the eligible
students in in the K-12 schools
I would just know because I'm glad if I
could um New Mexico
um requires their statute requires
um funding for the breakfast after
developed for all the schools but only
elementary schools have been funded so
far something yeah so it's a phase
yeah yeah
that was the one I think that it said it
doesn't apply to metal and nine through
as a former High School principal I I
would be reluctant to wave those
youngsters off and let them phase in
they're equally hungry in the morning
yeah
they're hungry right
they're big they're growing especially
Kelly thank you so very much for coming
again and being able to uh review the
information that you gave us you're
welcome I'm happy to whatever
information I can get I'm happy to
provide that yeah well we we
sincerely appreciate it you're welcome
okay so the last state that we looked at
was West Virginia
and
um you know how you have sister
communities in other countries or other
states I read West Virginia and I
thought oh these are a lot like the fine
folks in New Hampshire they require a
school nutrition program but it doesn't
have to be the federal one
the West Virginia feed to achieve act
requires the Board of Education to
establish and operate nutritional
programs for breakfast and lunch and the
legislation envisions building funding
through donations contributions payments
made by individuals
communities businesses organizations and
parents or Guardians on behalf of
students so what they're proposing is
their own nutrition system that each
School must provide breakfast and lunch
but they're going to uh basically at
least to some degree privately funded uh
as I said breakfast is required also
part of the Virginia code is the
requirement that each County Board and
Department of Education establish a fund
or a non-profit Foundation to accept
gifts grants or be Quests for the
purpose of funding approved School meals
programs
the funds may also be used
representative Woodcock to supply
students with nutritious Foods over the
weekend you and I had a conversation
about the 68 hours of hunger program
which
quite a few of our New Hampshire schools
are participating in the backpack
initiative that kids go home with a
backpack full of food at the end of the
week so that they can get over the
weekend before they're coming back to
school where many of them are having
their
most substantial food in intake during
the day
there's no school the school provides
the alternative Monday through Friday
but they still have nothing to eat on
the weekends that's exactly right rather
them all right uh West Virginia also is
uh has a shared table initiative
we looked into that last session we went
as far as uh adopting the frozen food
aspect of what to do with excess Foods
so we did take that step in West
Virginia they're also looking at the
health requirements through the USDA
through the county health boards and
also looking at what kinds of foods have
to be are allowed to be distributed we
talked a little bit about that last time
or around last session but we didn't
we we had we had information that where
we were limited and what could be
redistributed but
um
I don't know how that would apply to a
privately run program
you know if it's a privately run and
privately funded program I don't know
whether or not the law would be the same
but it's an interesting concept
representative Lucas yeah the the uh
what I've seen in a number of states it
seems like yeah they regulate all kinds
of stuff and even when people have had
meals you know Sunday lunch meals or
weekday meals in the park that volunteer
organizations were providing the
wonderful USDA came and shut them down
certainly discouraging if you're trying
to feed hungry kids right you know you
hate to see them
cherry picking off of their lunch trays
and then uh somebody who might want what
Muriel isn't going to eat is denied the
opportunity because murals had it
sitting in front of her so yeah
the program which we discussed several
years ago was the program in Indiana
and I'd be curious to know that was
where the leftover frozen food was taken
home and distributed to the families I'd
be curious to know how that program has
progressed
New Hampshire adopted its own program
curious to see there they started before
we did right right what they may have
found out about it or anything to make
it a stronger program that'd be great
for us yep
the other thing when we talk local when
we talk about local produce and locally
raised here I hope we don't go to the
degree that Maine has gone and it has to
be from the state of Maine
uh local up my neck of the woods is both
sides of the river
and in fact most of the land now that's
been farmed in New Hampshire is owned by
people in Vermont
and so I would think that we'd want to
have produce local by maybe some kind of
a radius or or or New England yeah
there's something we want to look at
I know the Hannaford when they're
selling food in the stores now they're
calling locally raised produced food is
from me and and uh which that's where
Hannaford's out of but uh that they
consider that still local here in uh
where I shop over in Bradford Vermont I
haven't seen that down in the Hanford
store in Plymouth but uh I think it's
important that we try to spread it out a
okay
okay so that's all I have in terms of
the research that Jen provided us with
at the very least I think we have a body
of information here that begs questions
uh that would be worthwhile to answer if
we can
certainly get answers to the questions
um
on a personal note I will say that I
again I'll go back to that word
disheartening I I have found it
disheartening not to be able to do
something about feeding hungry kids you
know uh and I I I understand that
we need to have Federal reimbursement
obviously to the best of our abilities
we need to be able to access the federal
dollars that are out there uh and you
know whether or not we should be looking
at how we go about collecting the data
on free and reduced lunch kids and
whether or not there is a way that we
can collect data to get higher
participation from people that are
actually eligible for the program I mean
that certainly would be something that I
would be interested in uh representative
Woodcock and I would call it from the
meeting we had with representative Ladd
and his committee on 1680 last week
There's clearly a lot of dialogue about
uh how we measure achievement
standardized tests and all those things
it seems pretty clear to me that
regardless how we measure uh those
numbers uh for the state Rick are going
to go up when we have a whole County of
youngsters New Hampshire that have fed
and get the nutrition the meal the in
every single day that our achievous boys
have to go up and have hungry kids try
to take tests you don't have to convince
me on that oh no no I agree with you I'm
there yeah no no are you my wife you
brought the light the other day yeah
yeah and my biggest concern is that I'm
looking at a number of programs which we
you know require or have for the state
has to support school districts in
various tasks like building a
and whether we have those programs
there's some ownership on the part of
the locals the state may provide uh 70
of a grant and 30 has to be done locally
I think with a little ownership in the
game I think that would help uh when
we're talking about you know 29 30
million dollars you know we're talking
about the availability of the school
building Aid each year of being now
upwards towards 25 million dollars a
year we out we appropriate 50 million
but half of that's David and so and and
the same thing with all those types of
programs so it'd be really it I I kind
of concur we shouldn't the phase in just
certain grades that's maybe one option
to try and get it in all grades is a
better option but to do that there may
be have to be some optional buy-in on
the part of the local saying that and
showing the benefits in marketing this
program properly and then I see in terms
of my town which is a rural community
but one that's always been very
thoughtful of social organizations when
it comes to our warrant articles they
would probably be the same when it came
to feeding kids
thank you my point was that youngsters
who get a good nice rest
and have a full nutritional uh system of
meals throughout the day I'm going to
succeed
academically better than those
youngsters that can't sleep at night
because they're hungry will come to
school hungry all day so the numbers
that we're talking in 1680 on the
academic achievement of New Hampshire
clearly this is one part of that that
could help thank you
representative Lucas
yeah I just wanted to mention two
cautions one is in uh saying that a
school one of the states said that all
schools must participate in the federal
program and the federal program mandates
all kinds of things including the type
of food Etc and if kids don't like it
they don't eat it look at Londonderry
they decided not to do it
because the kids were not eating the
food because they thought it was
disgusting and I can understand that I
remember Michelle Obama apples and my
daughter would take her Max Apple Farm
Apple in and say I have an apple I just
want to buy the carton of milk and
they'd say no you can't buy the carton
of milk unless you have a Michelle Obama
apple and the Michelle Obama apples were
hard and bitter and terrible and she had
a wonderful Max apple and so they ended
up with a barrel of apples that they fed
the donkeys with because we have an AG
School
and so I just want to wanna because they
weren't allowed to mandating serve the
so careful when we mandate things right
and then the other
um
Ronald Reagan jelly beans I totally
I took full full responsibility for that
representative Woodcock yeah I I
understand what you're saying
representative Lucas and I and I do
really as you would expect like the West
Virginia Way
I I think I even knew that before I
brought that up representative I guess
but I don't remember what the other
thing was totally yeah I mean like
anything else you know this we we all
acknowledge the fact that we have a pot
of money and that the money needs to be
distributed and used for different
things and uh at some level we all have
to decide uh
what are how our priorities are our rent
and you know uh representative Ladd will
talk about ctes with great passion and
authority and I will talk about hungry
kids in the cafeteria with equal passion
uh I won't say Authority though because
he probably did cafeteria Duty himself
when he was many years yeah
representative
I remembered what the other one was and
that's sharing personal data and that
was the problem with the Medicaid
Program is that they were sharing data
they would be sharing data with the
federal government that people didn't
necessarily want shared and given our
Constitutional Amendment which says you
know
another step towards guaranteeing
people's privacy we really have to look
at that before just saying oh we're
going to do this that's another number
that I would love to be able to get my
hands on like how many people uh you
know what what is the percentage of
people that would have difficulty
sharing their personal data we don't we
don't know you know that's uh
because of course they're not going to
share that because they don't want to
it's we are fooling ourselves thinking
the federal government doesn't have that
data right now when you have an uh IRS
is basically knows everything that's in
your forms there uh and we wouldn't be
through this Medicaid looking for
anything further than what's already
possessed by them so I think it's a
process which would allow us to uh
strengthen all our federal grants coming
to this state and we're looking at where
we can get more Revenue more sources of
money we would be look at the CTE
program that funding on basically when
we're looking at the Carl Perkins Grant
is based on part of the fnr uh
eligibility and and that it goes down
through all of the Esser stuff as well
so uh I think we should be open to
looking at every Avenue of revenue for
this state to function on so
um I kind of disagree a little bit with
that I think the Peds already have that
information
representative Ellison I just two quick
comments one based on our latest
discussion and I was on that that it was
a formal it was an informal study
committee that that Rick sat up set up
and we went through looking at sort of
free reduced price the issues we're
talking about what are the numbers how
can we improve them how and and and I
think and I mean I think I'm right that
there were four or five states who had
figured out how to use Medicaid data in
order to vastly increase the number of
students who are eligible for free
reduced price lunch so I I'm not in the
camp of saying well we got privacy
issues here so no State should do it
because some states are doing it uh
secondly just in terms of the the work
that we've done and we're going to do
there are a whole lot of issues that uh
questions issues that need to be studied
but I for one need to see action on this
kids have to be thin I do not want to
spend however many years I have left in
this body studying this issue
we need to move we need to move quickly
we need to get questions answered and I
think that's what's happening and and
Madam chair I would congratulate you on
moving us through this process very
rapidly uh but my patience has run out
president do you need do you need a uh
if you're willing to entertain are you
at the point and your deliberations and
you're thinking that you're willing to
entertain a motion to to uh take a vote
of this committee to see if we want to
continue the study and bring a forward a
positive affirmation to the uh committee
for the or or not or whatever well where
where are we in that uh process I know
you started with that's the culmination
right right that we're ready to
culminate well I had originally uh
indicated that I thought today would be
our last meeting day just because I felt
like we had heard
a lot of information from the public and
uh and our our own agencies and that
once we reviewed this
well done uh research that we would make
a decision so
um I I don't know how individual members
feel about making that determination
today I certainly would want to hear
from you okay possible for you to
restate the the frame as you did we when
we began a discussion today about what
vote is needed for affirmative or
negative for this I I am going to say it
and then I'm going to ask uh that the
man who knows more about how this works
uh if I say anything that is
untoward or out of line please let me
know I believe that our charge today
based on the fact that we are an interim
study committee on house bill
1229 which was a bill to establish a
study committee on food service programs
I believe that what the question we're
answering is whether or not we feel that
additional legislation
related to House Bill 1229 is
appropriate or not
uh let me read the title of that bill
because you're very close to what it
said 1229 establishing a committee to
study school meal programs in New
Hampshire Public Schools and
non-sectarian schools that accept public
funds so as to establish a committee
now what we had in the blurb on this was
the education committee has been
approached this year with several bills
that request we study what food programs
schools are using and what programs are
not working we have been approached with
bills that want to explore how Granite
State students can take advantage of our
natural resources in the Farms that will
benefit the students nutritionally and
our Farmers financially some questions
revolve around whether local resources
can alleviate supply chain issues and
whether we can rely on them
systematically for these reasons more we
need to decide on a preliminary
structure of how to study these topics
uh my my
understanding of where we are in
commissions and committees that we have
enough commissions and committees I
think it's time to say
we feel that there's no need to kick
this can down the road further that
there's no need for additional study or
a committee we need to bring forward
legislation of some kind to address the
issue of uh hunger in schools and and so
um and with some Snippets that you've
taken from your committee here
um so basically there's no need for this
bill to go forward this bill is a
committee study we've just done that and
and
um we've studied a lot of this over the
years and we have doe here that's able
to provide the information we have
research assistant Gen4 here also
um I think you're at the point where you
want to bring some legislation forward
based upon some of the discussions
you've had be it with West Virginia
Virginia Maine Delaware Etc
so the answer to the question would be
no we do not need additional study
we feel that additional legislation is
warranted in
the following areas the purpose of the
study has been met by this subcommittee
now we feel now take that next step
forward with
creative legislation that's going to you
know
meet some of these these goals in which
we have so you ought to come up with
some general aspirations that this
committee really wants to see yeah
um and so that that should be spoken to
you know if you're going to take that
vein then you want to really try to
speak a little bit too so
you don't have to
um it could be just brought forward it'd
be nice to keep it all on the same page
though yeah the only thing I'm thinking
about is whether or not that can be done
uh
whether or not I can put something
together and uh
circulate it or whether or not we have
to have another meeting
you could always you know put together
some bullets or what what whatever right
now and or in in a interim period here
we have till the 24th you could meet
early just before the committee of the
whole meets to take executing these
bills and possibly look at that
distribute this by way of you know email
to everybody and then come back in and
ask people that if any comments on one
just strike it and modify it a little
bit of whatever yeah uh then try to come
in and get that I don't think there's
need for any more study on this thing
all right then I will be looking for a
motion from somebody
to uh I'm looking for emotion made that
there is uh no further need for
additional study
and uh the following recommendations are
I think we'll tell you Allison who's
making that motion actually
no I think I I think uh representative
lekkas beat him to it so so you are
making the motion I make I move that we
recommend that a uh we there is no need
for a study committee that the work has
been done already
during our interim study and that
instead we recommend that legislation be
put forward in the following areas
to be filled out and agreed upon during
the next week or two
okay do I have a second
uh representative Ellison you second the
motion
okay
so with that in mind then I will ask for
a vote on the motion
and I'm just going to go from right to
left representative Woodcock yes
representative lekkis yes
and I am also a voting member and I am a
yes no uh chairman Ladd is not a member
thanks
yeah so so the motion passes anyhow yes
I just wanted to pass on one piece of
information I got since our last meeting
about the farm to school program when I
was last buying my vegetables at our
local Farm Stand I mentioned that we
were working on that and he said and he
just almost shouted it that won't work
in New Hampshire and I was kind of taken
back I'm like what he said Alvernon
Alvern approached them years ago and
they spent about three years trying to
figure out how to make it work he said
the problem is we're about done with our
Harvest about the time school starts and
so maybe they can provide things for
September October and that's it and so
he's and they did what he said we worked
really hard for like three or four years
trying to make it work and that's in the
southern part of the south central part
of the state where the weather is a
little better than up north
and I know other Farms that I know of in
the state they're pretty much in the
same I mean you have meat farms that
could provide meat for freezers or
whatever
but yeah the squash is about the end of
the season
squash and apples
representative Paul
I would say we grew potatoes up north
and they were year round we had them
right in our basement and we sold them
to the school year round so there are
some products that are year-round
and representative Allison and I would
suggest apples may fall into that
category correct yeah add those carrots
representative Woodcock did you have
something I got two things why not add
carrots to that are they still buy them
from our local Farm in January February
March
um but in all seriousness representative
I want to thank you
um for the diligence that you put in
this committee to make sure we all have
the information we needed and Jennifer
for her work
um this has been a pleasure to serve on
this with you and I appreciate your
leadership well thank you very much I
appreciate your comments uh it's as I
said near and near and dear to my heart
Uh Hungry kids
we've got work to do
don't give up on the locally grown stuff
either up in Grafton County we have a
Grafton County Farm which provides the
produce for the Grafton County Nursing
Home and it offsets the costs of food in
that particular County operation we also
have the food pantry in Woodsville which
we get donations from local stores be it
Shaw's or Hannaford and that's
distributed to those that are in need
within the community not to the schools
but there's no reason why programs like
this can't be also helping schools if we
look at the season and we look at you
know what the availability of what
produce or crop is there but there are a
number of small locally operated
operations here in the state I know the
commissioner came here represent Jasper
and he said well sustainability is a
major issue that you speak to
representative Lakers and I agree but I
wouldn't say that's enough rationale to
stop and not really pursue right
continue to pursue it yeah thank you
yeah
um I am interested before you all go
dashing out the door if you would like
to uh
speak to me about
what sort of recommendations you would
like to go into this report we can do
one of two things we can I can either
take your suggestions now we can
continue to meet or you can email me uh
have having digested this information
but I would ask that you email me within
the next couple of days or so so that I
can get this done with any
recommendations that resonated with you
from all of our discussions and I will
try to put something together yes
representative Hall I just wonder about
how we can capture these folks that
aren't
on the record as being free and reduced
but they really are and so that for me
is like how do we yeah how do we get
those folks because I think we used to
refer to those as the fourth stay nine
kids when I was in school that if you
were in one two and three you got loads
of services and if you were gifted and
talented you got services but yeah if
you're slightly above that eligibility
criteria or if you're eligible but you
don't have your family doesn't have the
wherewithal to know how to apply or when
to apply or yeah that would go beyond
that so I'm talking about the ones that
are do would certainly qualify I know
for myself personally I the cafeteria
woman when I would go to Lexington I
don't know why your parents don't with
uh sure you know
um and following up what representative
I just uh representative Vlad I want to
give representative Paul an opportunity
to finish okay so so it was why aren't
you and it wasn't they didn't have the
wherewithal
it was just they chose not to the the
pride and whatnot and so I think that
there are people
um in that category I'm guessing
so how do we catch that so when I was a
principal
and I'm sure our reps in whitcock you've
done the same thing
um you knew that there were some kids
which were eligible that were not
bringing this into school for a either
the upper levels of middle school or
high school but we checked them off as
receiving that we we used our ability to
make an exception
by allowing the student to qualify we
qualify them the administrators all the
principals in the district got together
and we went through all these
applications every October
um so is that something that's done
still today is it legal or what
um
that is not done today
um there are certain circumstances
um that
it could be
um depending upon the situation
um but in the way that you're describing
it it
um would not happen
um in that way so if we had a an
application from Susan Jones down in the
sixth grade and the parent said you know
we also have Johnny and Ralph and etc
etc in our family and the other grades
that wouldn't suffice
no that's a different situation
um so the families now only have to fill
out one application they can include
everybody on that application
um so they would be all encumbrance of
whoever is in the household
um and it's a local level
um at the Department of Education we
don't have anything to do with that
determine determination and eligibility
that's done at a local level so it's in
fact the nutrition directors that are
the ones that are doing that again due
to you know data privacy and and privacy
of those people that fill out those
applications that's something that's
very um taken very seriously is this a
state application no it's a USDA
application it's USD does on that
application does it say please fill out
all children within your family on that
individual application or to say State
the it's coming from elementary to
school X so you're filling out as a
parent the kids which are attending
Elementary X school not including your
other children in the instructions it
um just to finish that's just part of
um the packet that goes to every single
student at the beginning of every single
school year that's a required that's a
USDA requirement printed out and handed
to every single student
representative Ladd if we had an office
of School counseling at the Department
of Education
that person would be able to tell you
that it is a school counselor's purview
to reach out to families to be in touch
with families to uh and or a school
social worker if they're in existence I
I would agree but I also agree as a
principal and an assistant principal in
your building we laid it on ourselves to
get that done and didn't have to be
necessarily the counselor or it could be
anybody in the administration doing it
and we did make those contacts but it
would be nice if they in instead of
saying just house all household members
including children yeah
I also think too that you know the
stigma and shame of of hunger
is huge it is huge we I know staff
members in buildings that are hesitant
to address
a family a parent you know they've got
kids in their classrooms that are hungry
and they're hesitant because they don't
want to make the parent feel
uncomfortable or have the parent think
that somehow or another there's judgment
involved but uh but no kid you know no
family no child should feel shame over
Hunger yes representative Woodcock thank
you um
I'm I'm I
I was under the misnomer when we were
talking with representative Ladd's uh
other committee about Medicaid and
helping that the large applications a
lot of youngsters are included I was
still thinking that we were losing
youngsters in the upper levels because
they weren't included can you tell me
what year we changed that I mean I'm I
was really on the wrong information that
all youngsters were included under one
application
as far as I as long as I have been in
Child Nutrition which will this will be
my 11th year they have always been on
the application wow um and they're
they're approved on one application yes
the family can fill out one application
right um so I had that misinformation on
my brain thank you no terrific um and
the local level
um you know it's a best practice and
that they they make that connection and
look in their system to make sure that
they're connecting
um those two together and and the way
the application
um is separated out students are at the
top you can identify what school they're
at
um and there's there's different
criteria in that and that's when the
bottom is when where the parents are
parents Guardians um
they're identifying follow up to that so
when a student is attending Woodsville
High School who is from Bath
um New Hampshire
uh that's a separate School District
within the co uh within the school
administrative district and school
administrative Union and does bath then
contact Woodsville High School
or the central office for SAU 23 that
this kid in bath
along with those other students which
are attending your high school there in
Woodsville are eligible or or is that
something that's just kept that path and
we miss out on that child that's maybe
attending the older one that's attending
the high school that's on the that other
application comes in a bath
I can't speak particularly to that
situation I'd have to look at the SAU to
find out the makeup of do they have one
nutrition director do they
um I would like to say I'm fluent in all
of the saus but in my 10 months director
right there in North Haverhill okay and
so it's it and she has quite a burden
trying to collect money that's owed to
them and on and on it goes but I'm I'm
just hoping we're counting all the kids
and even from those sending communities
like Benton and bath and Warren and
Piermont all those communities we want
to catch them all and the applications
although they're done at the local
school district
um they are collected at the SAU level
so that would be
um fully captured at the SAU level
because there's certain
um steps that need to be done as per the
USA USDA on verification of the
applications and so on and so forth so
that's done at an FAU level and not at a
other questions for
representative just to comment all these
brilliant brains here we need to be look
trying to
think outside the box and see if there's
another way of figuring out needy
students other than free and reduced
lunch or needs in a community or
whatever because we base everything on
free and reduced lunch and then when we
don't get applications filled out or
whatever we don't get it so we need to
be trying to I don't know see if there's
some totally different way we haven't
looked at yet to figure out where needs
are and where they aren't because free
and reduced lunch has issues I would
agree with you just it's just that so
much funding is attached to the data for
free and reduced lunch uh that while
we're thinking outside the box I think
we got to do a better job at collecting
numbers too so Kelly can I ask you a
question
um
okay in your office it's the office of
school nutrition is that what that what
you're
um yes nutrition programs and services
okay all right I
things uh how many people are working in
that office
um currently right now we have six okay
and that is encumbrance of
um not only national school lunch so we
handle the child and adult care programs
summer programs
um
fresh fruit and vegetable program
special milk program so all of the Child
Nutrition programs that are funded by
if I if I were evil I would ask you
whether or not you think that you have
adequate Staffing in your office but uh
you I I don't know that you could
probably answer that question I
appreciate not and and answering that
question well I just want you to know
I'm thinking it thank you thank you
you're welcome I think she's a volunteer
yes I I would agree
representative Paul I was just going to
follow up on an earlier statement that I
made I want to make clear that I would I
do not go to school hungry and our
family was probably the best one best
fed family in town living on a farm so I
didn't want to suggest that I went to
school hungry because I definitely did
not
representative Fleck is
so I have a question you you deal with
fresh fruits and vegetables and all that
kind of stuff
um and the program we were talking about
Farm to school had an administrator and
testing and you just all kind you know
tracking food and all kinds of stuff
if we were to do if we were to and that
seemed like it was going to spend a
chunk of the available money on on
overhead and administration so the
question is
um
I guess if we had a volunteer program
the schools with the local
Farms
would we need administration at the at
your level and would you be able to do
you know help out with that with the
people and funding that you have now
with the current funding with the
current people that you have you know
the funding for your admin your
employees and with the current staff
that you have now as far as just helping
schools make arrangements if they want
to do it if things have to be done I
sure
uh okay so just a reminder that you're
going to email me
with potential suggestions for
legislation or areas of uh study or
investigation or whatever however you
want to phrase it
thank you very much
uh and I will put something together and
then
I would assume that what that we're
probably going to do what representative
Ladd had suggested and that is meet ever
so briefly on the morning of the 24th
before the meeting begins
we're here for a full day I'm not sure
what time we're coming in that day we
started
starting up a work deal we at one
o'clock so I'm hoping to get things done
in the morning right so you're gonna
have if you're going to meet briefly
before yep the meaning you should put it
in the calendar because it's going to be
um
would you all be able to meet at nine
foreign
I'm just procedurally I'm just wondering
whether or not it has to be uh a meeting
that can be witnessed whether it has to
be a public meeting so
you could do it in two minutes yeah yeah
all right 9 15 Jen would you mind uh
asking Lindsay if she'll
notice that
and then I will make sure that you folks
have the document ahead of time but we
will just for the sake of public record
be able to uh read it into do you know
if one that on that day all the
oh yeah this are all the Committees
having something on that day no okay so
I guess my question too is and it just
for Expedition Expediting the issue if
uh you could have the meeting in another
room since Rick's meeting at 9 30 people
will be assembly while we're trying to
do this stuff if you could just let me
I was really hoping
not a horrible idea just trying to
follow procedure so that we're legit
that's all
so Jen for my edification I could would
you set that meeting at nine
and
yeah and that way if people get stuck in
traffic if there's uh so we'll we'll
meet at nine on the 24th
and that way we'll be uh sorry about
that representative Woodcock will be as
gentle as we possibly can be if you're
late
so beforehand we can be
putting comments ins and saying no
please change no I don't you know Etc so
that pretty much by the time we're done
with our document
we're ready to go
we adjourn this meeting uh I second that
thank you very much everybody for coming
in today and I will see some of you next